how many alien civilization do you think
are out there
zero one or many
so
if you say civilization
i
would bring my number way down
it could be zero
if you talk about life
i think it could be many
as we were saying before i think the
move from life
to consciousness the kinds of beings
that would build what we would recognize
as a civilization
that may be extraordinarily
rare i hope it's not
you know as a kid i love star trek i
just love the idea that we would be part
of some
universal community where look
experience on planet earth suggests it
doesn't always go so well when groups
who are separated try to come together
and and live in some larger collective
but again as an optimist
how amazing would it be to converse with
an alien civilization and and learn what
they've figured out about physics and
cosmology and and compare notes and and
learn from each other in in some some
wonderful way i i love that idea but if
you ask me
the likelihood of it
i would err on saying
it may be so improbable
that the conditions conspire to allow
life to move to this place of of
consciousness and it might be rare
it might be over simplifying things but
just observing the power of the
evolutionary process
i tend to believe
and like you read
different theories of how we went
uh
how homo sapiens evolved
it seems like the evolutionary process
naturally leads to
to
the homo sapiens
or creatures like that or much better
than that so to me the
there's several scary scenarios so
okay the positive scenario is life
itself is really difficult so that
origin of life is difficult that's
exciting for many reasons
because
we might be able to prove that wrong
easily in the near term by finding life
elsewhere sure
the scary thing to me is if uh
life is easy
and there's plenty of conscious
intelligent civilizations out there and
we have not
obviously made contact which means
with intelligence and consciousness
comes
responsibility and uh
ultimately
destruction
so with power comes great responsibility
and then we end up destroying ourselves
that's the
uh the scariest the the positive i guess
version is that
maybe we're being watched
uh sort of like
there's a transition
to where you don't want to ruin uh the
primitive villages out there and so
there's a protective layer around us
yeah they're they're watching
you